absentee rates are going up so sickness
rates are going up
that's sort of in line with the amount
of cobin i think that's in the system so
we've got usually in the nhs sickness
rates run around four to five percent
now they're at near eight or nine
percent and they're creeping upwards
and so you've done some modeling to to
look at how omicron could affect that
absentee rate in the future and what
have you found
so we model different different kinds of
scenarios to help people make the best
decisions that they can around the
resources that they have
we know that there are increasing rates
of sickness we expect those increasing
rates to sickness to go up not only for
this surge but also well into next year
because of the effects of things like
issues with mental health and long
covered
and so what we do is we help people with
different scenarios so 40 we would hope
would be a worst case scenario
but we are already working with
organizations that are reporting around
25 28 sickness
how hard is it though to forecast
given that you're talking about a
variant omicron that has only recently
been identified and all the data is so
new and coming in all the time
it's very difficult to do that kind of
forecasting which is why we model
different scenarios
so we model you know best case scenarios
and worst case scenarios to help people
make those decisions
but we do know that you know we went
into the pandemic with a massive
workforce deficit in health care almost
100 000 people and 50 000 registered
nurses and so i don't think it takes
very much imagination to understand that
a
system that's already under a lot of
pressure with an extremely high demand
um is going to have issues with meeting
that demand in future
well yes and is it possible to say
whether or not um
hospitalizations and the rise in the
number of people going into hospital is
going to have more of an impact on the
nhs than staff shortages or the other
way around is it possible to make that
assessment i think the two are
interrelated and also the focus is
generally on hospitals but also staff
shortages are going to impact the
community so most care is actually
delivered in the community in general
practice and in areas like district
nursing and we know that those services
are being quite profoundly affected they
are already running a workforce deficit
and um the latest surge is putting more
pressure on those groups too
what about the the change in
advice as far as self-isolation is
concerned once somebody tests positive
that's been dropped in this country from
10 days to seven that will make a real
difference won't it
it makes a difference in terms of the
availability of staff and but i think
that's probably more in other sectors a
lot of the organizations that we're
working with
are choosing really to stick with the 10
days um
while they can and i think that's that's
really about helping to um look after
their workforce actually as much as
anything
that's so interesting because also we've
also heard that in the us they're now
changing their advice
to drop the self-isolation days from
seven to five days so do you think that
even if that was even considered in this
country it might not be observed
it's one of the things that's quite
difficult to take out from the data at
the moment is how many people are
isolating due to being ill with covid
and how many people are in isolation
because they've had a positive cover
test or an asymptomatic
uh because that would have a big impact
in terms of workforce
and because we can't really pull that
data out at the moment it makes it kind
of difficult to say what the impact
would be
do you think what do you think or what
are you hearing about the reaction
within the nhs to the government's
decision
not to put in new restrictions at least
before the new year
they will say that they've looked at
these studies
which suggest that omicron is less
severe that the chances of
hospitalization are up to 70
lower than previous
variants
do you think there is an understanding
within the health service of that logic
i think there is but even a small
percentage of a very big number is a
very big number in terms of
possible admissions we are seeing
admissions going up
and we haven't even reached that peak
yet i think the workforce generally is
is in quite a dire state
um certainly anecdotally a lot of the
people that we speak to are absolutely
exhausted
and they've been through several waves
of um covid now
um
and i think that
generally
it would be good if they felt a little
bit more supported
and by supported what do you mean
i think in terms of things like
government policy so you know a lot of
the issues that we see in terms of
workforce in healthcare currently are
long-standing government policies around
things like investment in front line
services
issues around ppe still do exist we see
that quite a lot and i think your
previous speaker was saying about the
you know how essential it is to
recognize that covert is airborne and
that things like the guidance need to be
updated in terms of ppe
the recognition of long covid and how
that impacts on the workforce
you know the ons are reporting around 40
000 people are predicted to have long
covered in health care and social care
and that's not an insignificant amount
of people
what about um the fact that we are
getting the likes of sir john bell he's
been talking this morning the
government's life sciences advisor he
has said that omicron is not the same
disease that we were seeing a year ago
he's pointed out that people appear to
be spending
shorter amounts of time in hospital even
though hospitalization rates are on the
rise is that reassuring
i think in some ways it's reassuring
but again we we have a system that was
already under pressure before the
pandemic
um
we've also got a system that you know
has a has now very long waiting lists
and um issues with providing routine
care and therefore that's just going to
put more pressure on the workforce so
any extra demand even if it's you know
much better than we hoped for is going
to put pressure on the workforce